♪♪
>>> In our health lead today, a
hearing in the biggest
abortion-related case since the
U.S. Supreme court overturned
roe V. Wade, depending upon how
a trump-appointed judge in Texas
handles this lawsuit.
Access to the most common method
of abortion, pills, could be cut
off nationwide.
CNN's Rosa flores explains how
this could happen even in states
where abortion is perfectly
legal.
>> Reporter: The national
abortion debate, heating in a
federal courthouse in Amarillo,
Texas.
Inside, the biggest legal battle
over abortion since the supreme
court overturned roe V. Wade.
A federal judge is seriously
considering undoing fda approval
of mifepristone, an abortion
medication available for more
than two decades in a lawsuit
brought by an anti-abortion
coalition.
>> The impact in overruling the
fda's approval of mifepristone
is far reaching.
Doctors and patients will not
know if we can trust the
national guidelines which tell
us to follow the standard of
care.
>> Reporter: During the
four-hour preliminary injunction
hearing the judge raised one
possible scenario where he could
keep the drug's approval intact,
and instead block the fda's
rules to make it easier to
obtain.
>> It's a 20-year-old drug
actually used to save women's
lives.
>> Reporter: Legal concerns
always restricting access.
Walgreens plans to stop the sale
of the pill after states
threatened to sue.
In this case, the plaintiffs are
arguing the drug is unsafe.
And the fda's approval process
was flawed.
The women's March and other
abortion advocacy groups say the
plaintiffs went, quote, judge
shopping for someone they
believe will rule in their
favor.
There's one federal judge,
Matthew Kaczmarek, a president
trump appointee who went working
on anti-abortion advocacy to the
federal bench.
>> It would be unprecedented for
a judge, a single judge, to say
the fda got it wrong 23 years
ago.
There's never been an instance
where anyone has overturned the
rooming of the fda against the
fda wishes.
>> Reporter: Judge kacsmaryk's
hearing had been shrouded in
secrecy, the judge saying he
didn't want to out of security
concerns.
Sparking outrage over lack of
transparency.
>> I'm dressed like a clown to
show what a circus he's created.
It's just a joke.
He's making the American court
system into a circus.
>> Reporter: More than half of
the abortions in the U.S. In
recent years were medication
abortions most using
mifepristone.
>> And mifepristone is not just
used in abortion care, it's also
used for miscarriage management.
>> Reporter: The judge didn't
rule from the bench today.
And said he'd issue an opinion
as soon as possible.
Now, about what could be in that
opinion, in the judge's
questioning, he hinted at being
sympathetic towards the legal
arguments of the plaintiffs.
But and this nuance is
important, in his many
questions, he also showed some
skepticism towards granting an
order that would be as
aggressive as the plaintiffs
would want.
Jake.
>> All right, Rosa flores, in
Amarillo, Texas.
Let's bring in Katie Watson an
associate professor of
obstetrics and gynecology at
northwestern.
She's also an attorney.
If the plaintiffs, a group of
docks, medical associations that
oppose abortion, if they do get
this preliminary injunction, it
would forcing the fda, correct
me if I'm wrong, to withdrew the
approval of the drug
mifepristone, while his lawsuit
playing out.
How would this theoretically
affect women in the country
practically speaking?
>> I think the impact is not
theoretical.
We know over half of people
choosing abortion choose
medication abortion.
In two-thirds.
United States where abortion is
legal, it would remove this
popular method of abortion.
So, essentially this is
anti-abortion plaintiffs trying
to control the choices of people
who live in states where
abortion is legal.
And it would absolutely
unprecedented dramatic overreach
to have a federal judge tell the
fda what to do.
>> It is interesting because
we've heard a lot of
anti-abortion leerl scholars
after overturn of roe V. Wade,
well this is going to kick it
back to the states and that's
where it belongs.
You're saying this would be much
more aggressive than that?
>> No, this completely counters
that fabrication.
The idea is to control abortion
nationally.
And when these plaintiffs say
that medication causes harm, as
a medical ethicist, I'll tell
you, I think what they mean,
they perceive all abortion as a
sort of moral harm.
But that's not how the fda works
or what science is based on.
So they've made speechous claims
to the court.
>> Let's talk about the women
that live in the 31 state where
is this kind of medication
abortion is legal.
And if suddenly it's made
illegal and women can't get it,
and girls can't get it and they
need to get an abortion for
whatever reason, what would
these women do?
>> Well, let's be clear about
what's on the table and what we
don't know.
So, this case specifically
targets a drug called
mifepristone which is the first
of two drugs used in a
medication abortion regiment.
And so, it's possible that a
ruling would still have the drug
that's been on the market and
stalked in pharmacies and been
around for decades.
And so people could in those
states where abortion is
generally legal do that only
regiment.
Which is my understanding is 5%
or 10% less effective, and much
less comfortable for the
patient.
A two-drug standard is really
the gold standard.
It's possible that people will
go with that or a procedural
abortion.
The problem with that, that
requires an actual visit tie
clinic, whereas, medication
abortion can be done with
telemedicine.
Even folks driving from states
where it's illegal, to states
where it's legal, had the
opportunity in recent months to
cross the border, do a
telemedicine visit from their
car.
And the hope was that they could
fill it at a pharmacy, giving
them access as well.
That will be much more limited.
>> Yeah.
And, correct me if I'm wrong,
but I believe mifepristone is
approved and prescribed only to
end the pregnancies through ten
weeks.
So, when people talk about using
it -- like, we're not talking
about third trimester, so this
is plaintiffs trying to -- am I
wrong?
Correct me if I'm wrong.
>> No, you're completely
correct.
It's fda approved to ten weeks
used nationwide off of
tremendous studies of efficacy
to 11 weeks.
Now, the majority, vast
majority, almost 90% of American
abortions happen within that
first trimester.
So we're absolutely not talking
second or third trimester
abortions.
But we are talking about the
vast majority of abortions which
happen in the first trimester.
And half of those patients are
choosing these drugs so they can
do it at home.